there is something very appealing and
attractive about not caring a disregard
for consequence and judgment
a calm cool collected nurse that sets
the individual free the truth is it's
not realistic nor is it healthy or
practical to not care at all about
anything we are all wired to care about
things in order to survive and connect
to life even those who appear to not
care at all still care but there is
however a certain amount of not caring
that is realistic healthy and practical
a way to frame your perspective so that
you care about the right things the
right amount no more no less that is the
goal to care but not too much we should
care about our self our passions our
loved ones and life in general
life is inexplicably beautiful and
there's nothing else to do with it other
than to squeeze it for all it's worth
but yet at the same time life is
immensely complicated and uncertain and
it is fundamentally indifferent to how
much you care about it so we should not
care too much about life's imperfections
including our own or the little things
that seem far worse in the moment but
never really end up affecting anything
or the things that go wrong or not as
planned
even when we try our best because no
matter how much we try no matter how
much we want or don't want something no
matter how fair or unfair
life will never go exactly how we always
wanted to and so the trick is that we
take life serious enough to still be
motivated to participate in it and
appreciate it to pursue our passions
goals and a healthy fulfilling life but
not take it so serious that we forget to
admit that failure and imperfection are
inevitable that trial and tribulation
are synonymous with life to feel the
pains of life but to let things quickly
scab up keel over and then move on to
refrain from dwelling and picking up the
scam to practice forgiveness for the
self and forgiveness for others to learn
and grow from hardship and come out on
the other side inevitably life is going
to smack you around at least a little
bit you're going to make mistakes
experience failure and tragedy receive
negative feedback and so on but by
taking life a little less serious
understanding and sympathizing with the
idea that life in the universe is vastly
complex and random you will not break
under such pressures things might be
hard and things might hurt at times but
they will not break you and better yet
they will build and strengthen
you are like a muscle in the body the
more pressure and stress you are able to
withstand without breaking the stronger
and more powerful you will become if you
can recognize the balance of taking
things seriously but not too much you
will be able to more easily withstand
life's weight you will find yourself
becoming more and more calm resilient
and ultimately successful because those
who truly succeed and care about life
recognize that sometimes caring too much
about life ruins it thank you for
watching if we found enjoyment and value
in this video please give it a thumbs up
share your thoughts in the comments
below and if you are not already be sure
to subscribe to our channel we are
constantly coming out with new videos to
help you experience life with clarity
and wonder